Marketing is one of the most important aspects
of a film.
In the months leading up to its release, the
studio puts together trailers, posters, and
other materials to make the project appeal
to the widest audience possible.
Even when a movie is a surefire hit at the
box office, stellar advertising can be the
reason it goes on to break records instead
of just posting decent figures.
There’s no denying that film marketing has
become an art form and can play a large role
in how viewers perceive what’s coming through
the pipeline.
Here are 10 of the greatest marketing campaigns
of all-time.
Deadpool
Thought of as a risk by 20th Century Fox,
they finally rolled the dice on an R-rated
Deadpool film and it exceeded even the rosiest
expectations.
A major assist has to be given to the film’s
marketing campaign, which remained true to
the Deadpool character throughout.
Ryan Reynolds was a willing participant in
several YouTube videos where he appeared in
character, and the trailers illustrated that
this wasn’t your typical superhero movie.
Perfectly blending comedy and action, the
Deadpool campaign was hugely successful and
helped the film become the highest-grossing
R-rated film ever made.
It kept going all the way through the Blu-ray
release, so Fox knew they had a winner.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
When Disney and Lucasfilm announced Star Wars
Episode 7 would hit theaters in 2015, it was
already a massive blockbuster.
But once the Mouse House started revving up
the promotional campaign, anticipation and
hype reached a fever pitch.
The trailers smartly avoided any major plot
spoilers, and instead focused on the tone
and nostalgia for the brand.
Not every film can boast that its previews
made fans tear up with joy.
Add in events like Force Friday to celebrate
the arrival of tie-in merchandise, and it
was a magical time to follow the galaxy far,
far away.
Everything paid off, as Force Awakens broke
just about ever box office mark.
The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan got people buzzing for his
Batman sequel in the final scene of Batman
Begins, revealing the Joker card.
The ensuing marketing campaign for The Dark
Knight sent fans into a frenzy.
Using viral marketing, a website for Harvey
Dent was launched, giving viewers their first
look at Heath Ledger’s Joker.
Easter eggs at Comic-Con 2007 and even Dominos
Pizza provided fans with more reveals to drum
up the hype and anticipation.
It all ended with people gathering in New
York and Chicago to watch a Bat signal light
up to celebrate the arrival of the film, which
earned unprecedented acclaim.
Not to mention, the trailers were pretty great
too.
Avatar
History has proven that you don’t underestimate
James Cameron.
He clearly knows what he’s doing.
The director held off releasing a trailer
for Avatar for as long as possible, unveiling
the first completed footage at a first-of-its-kind
special invite event where curious viewers
got treated to a sizzle reel of IMAX 3D footage
and merchandise.
While this was happening, the standard trailer
and tie-in product information was released
to the general public, showing people what
the fan-favorite director had been working
on for years.
Avatar was such a mystery at the time, that
only added to the appeal and made people want
to see what it was all about.
Box office records and a Best Picture nomination
followed.
Cloverfield
J.J. Abrams is known for his infamous mystery
box, where he keeps the twists and turns of
his latest project under wraps until the film’s
premiere.
This arguably got started back on Cloverfield.
The first trailer for the creature feature
was a surprise attachment to the first Transformers
movie in 2007, telling moviegoers that if
they wanted more, they had to head to 1-18-08.com.
The website told a story that ran parallel
to the film’s actual narrative, setting
the stage for the world without revealing
any crucial details.
Abrams kept the focus on the monster instead
of the characters to manage expectations and
Cloverfield became a hit.
The Blair Witch Project
Back before found footage movies became popular,
the style was very convincing.
Some viewers actually believed they were watching
a real documentary.
The Blair Witch Project maintained this illusion
all the way to the film’s premiere.
Website blairwitch.com spoke of a legend that
only “grew” as new “information” was
added from a variety of sources.
The actors didn’t do any publicity, and
the IMDb page listed them as “missing, presumed
dead” to draw audiences in.
By the time the movie premiered, everyone
wanted to see what it was about, and Blair
Witch turned a $20,000 budget into $258 million
worldwide.
The campaign was so good and of its time,
it can never be replicated.
Ex Machina
When working with a smaller film, studios
have to get creative to raise awareness.
For Ex Machina, viewers were targeted in a
very personal way: on their phones.
During the SXSW film festival in 2015, users
of the Tinder app were approached by a woman
asking deep existential questions about love
and what it means to be human.
After engaging in a brief conversation, the
girl would send people a link to an Instagram
page, which included the poster and trailer
for Ex Machina.
It was a sneaky bit of promotion and probably
rubbed some singles the wrong way, but the
sci-fi film found a following and launched
that Tinder girl – Alicia Vikander – to
stardom.
The Social Network
For casual audiences, it was hard to see how
a film about Facebook’s origins could make
for compelling cinema.
Even with David Fincher at the helm, it seemed
too tough a premise to sell.
But after the teaser trailer, the doubters
were silenced.
Set to a haunting cover of Radiohead’s Creep,
the preview illustrated that there was much
more to the site’s beginnings than anyone
could have envisioned.
It made a strong impression, as did the tagline
“You don’t get to 500 million friends
without making a few enemies.”
Not only was The Social Network one of the
most acclaimed films of 2010, it performed
very well at the box office, meaning the campaign
worked at highlighting the intrigue.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Marvel Studios had an up-and-down year in
2013 with the lukewarm reactions to Iron Man
3 and Thor: The Dark World.
They needed to mix things up to reinvigorate
the brand, and the Guardians of the Galaxy
were the answer.
Taking characters even the most devout comics
reader was unaware of and turning them into
movie stars is no easy task, but a catchy
soundtrack and trailers showcasing pulpy space
opera thrills were more than enough to get
the job done.
It was apparent this would be different than
any previous Marvel movie, which was a welcomed
development.
The Guardians are now just as marketable as
their Avengers counterparts, which was unthinkable
only a few years ago.
Those are our picks for the best movie marketing
campaigns.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones sold you on a film?
Sound off in the comments and be sure to subscribe
for more fun videos!